hi guys from putnam county west virginia
we're back baby what's going on son
what's happening what's happening
dynamite here baby where's my crazy bird
where's my kids hey man what do you baby
all day ain't going nowhere we'll be
here until the day i die
all right zach
yes sir zach where'd you grow up where
are you from originally pogo west
virginia and tell me about uh your
childhood you had both your with your
mom and dad growing up no i had just my
just my dad well
like a mom figure my grandma was was
there but my mom pretty much abandoned
me at birth um don't really know exactly
how to go about that but i had my dad
and he was he was the
the more parent i've seen every day i
lived with him
how would you describe your childhood
rough
rough
it was it was rough
yes definitely what ways
uh just growing up with uh
the want of a boy wanting his mother is
always strong especially whenever you're
you know at such a young age five and
under you know you're gonna be one there
right there by your mama's hip you know
and
so i ran my grandma
absolutely rampant you know i mean i ran
her rampant because i you know i wanted
my mom all the time and she was the only
one that was there so was my dad
but it was it was a hard childhood um
got picked on a lot in school and didn't
have mom and dad was kind of uh abusive
in ways but
it was
uh
i don't really know man it was it was it
was really rough that's yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh kind of kid was on high school um
well i lost my dad my freshman year at
high school
and then uh
i ended up getting placed in placement
center not even three months after you
died i didn't want to go to placement i
just wanted somebody to understand that
hey you know i'm grieving and how'd you
lose your dad he died on a four-wheeler
out heiser creek about a mile from my
house
he was uh he was working where
no he was riding forward oh just four
weeks yeah yeah he got on the
four-wheeler and he done this every day
you know he'd come home from work and
you know he was up there at jager
building the military base up there
while he was wiring and he was
electrician
and
you know he'd come home every day and it
wasn't you know nothing for my dad to go
you know get on the four-wheeler and say
hey i'm rolling jerry's you know hop
down the road and come back an hour or
two later yeah oh this time you know he
leaves at 6 30 and
doesn't come back and you know i get a
knock on the door at 6 40 saying that
he's in the creek and
slap boulders off of four-wheeler and
everything so
i ended up losing him september 12th of
2011 that day so my high school
pretty much was screwed after that it
went to [ __ ]
and you lived with uh who after that my
grandma she uh bless her heart and my
grandpa too but
my grandma's mom had a trailer put next
to my grandpa's log cabin out hyzer
and
well when her mom died my dad ended up
getting her trailer put off and he put a
trailer there so when he died i took the
trailer over with my grandma until i
come of age to be able to pay the bills
and
all that other good stuff so i ended up
living with her until 18 and i lost her
in 2017.
and what after you graduate high school
would you do um
well
i ended up trying to go
and starting into school but that didn't
work out so i ended up going and doing
environmental management landscaping
over and over did you finish high school
yeah i do yeah i'm graduate class of
2014.
yep and uh
like a lot of people down here
in this part of the country drugs are a
part of the picture
oh yeah were they for you as well
oh yeah um
it started like
i'm 25 now i didn't it didn't start
until i was 20 but that was after
a lot of a lot of mental exhaustion you
know i mean i lost you know dad i didn't
snap from my dad until 2014 and then
me and my son's mom split up and that
just kind of sent me over the deep end
and
you know i didn't want to be here
anymore you know i got real suicidal and
then drugs started getting into the play
with it and i was on day report so i
couldn't really smoke any marijuana or
anything so i just didn't want to be
here anymore so i started doing that it
was like i said it's telling you earlier
it's in prolonging or not prolonging but
just helping speed up the process of an
inevitable death this is indirect
suicide
so i did that for about two years on and
off and now so what was your drug mostly
methamphetamine that's it's it's real
down here man it's it's real yeah
crystal meth and heroin are yeah the big
drugs yep it's it's real it's no joke i
lose friends over it all the time i've
lost one of my best friends john baker
he's 43 years old
the man i was in logan and he called me
crying saying that he needed me he
needed me to need me and i didn't get to
him and then the next day i get a phone
call and he was found laying up over
there at a
hot dog place over in cross lanes
and uh yeah drugs are so prevalent down
here for your generation it is it is
how many i mean what percentage of your
friends are using drugs
if i had to honestly if i had to say out
of all the guys that i knew and all the
girls that i knew growing up from school
man i'd have to say at least if somebody
ain't popping pills or if one of them
ain't drinking or it's
or it could be they're hard dope i mean
it's
i'd have to say like 60 70 160 70 from
my class or any of the other people that
i grew up that was from a older class or
under me
i've i see that too yeah
you know what do you think the reason
for that is
personal opinion the reason for that
lack of stability
structure
might be an in-home thing with the
parents because a lot of the kids around
this generation honestly they don't want
to work either say all they want to do
is just you know party and
do drugs man so that's a lot of it is
the younger generation but
and aside from hunting or or
you know just walking the mountains
there's not a whole lot to do here oh i
mean
you got hunting you got white water
rafting you can go down the new river i
go down there all the time and hitting i
got to camp there i do fishing i'll fish
on the greenbrier in the new um it's a
beautiful part of the country oh yeah
it's it really is it's it's beautiful
and hidden it's absolutely beautiful you
have it been i mean you go
spectacular yes
but uh but still there's so much
addiction there is it's it's everywhere
there is no place that you can go that
doesn't have it what do you think of the
future for this region with so much of
your generation
i'm hoping that it doesn't
that
i'm hoping that everything doesn't
continue to decline and you know go to
fault like it is
because it is it's slowly withering away
i mean i can see half of half of my my
kids from my class are
you know i'm
i am one of them statistics i did
mess around with it that's my bad deed
and you know you gotta be accountable
for it now i am one part of that
statistic but
it's real
yeah it's it's not a joke it's that's
killing us yeah
so currently are you using still or no
i've been clean since
august
12th i would want to say yeah august
12th of
it's 2021 now so august of 2019
because my son's birthday was on the
16th and that was when i was in logan
was whenever i was my buddy john baker
called me
and it just really hit me it was like
you know he got hit with a hot shot he
didn't
i don't i don't think he did a hot shot
though what i think happened is this uh
he ended up doing too much of one or the
other together
and it slowed and blew his heart and i
heard about that and it killed me
to where
i like to drink a beer every once in a
while i didn't even want to touch
marijuana i didn't want to touch beer
man it's just
it hurt me you know i mean he was 43
years old but that man was like we was
together every day yeah and then your
young son yeah gave you another reason
yeah
and my son man his
first two years after mine and his mom
you know split
i take accountability for it i take
responsibility for it i shouldn't i
should have been there but in my eyes i
didn't want to give him another my mom
you know i mean i didn't want to
pretend that i'm there
and
not you know even when i'm there i'm not
there yeah but you're currently you're
raising your son yeah well me and his
mom do split i'll have him yeah she'll
have him throughout the week or if i
have available time i'll come and pick
him up throughout the week and keep him
and take him to school
i got court-ordered visitations with him
on the weekends
so
he's he's my inspiration he's my drive
that's great
and you're working currently oh yeah
yeah what do you do now i work at
wendy's right now on nitro i'm getting
ready to start trying to train for
management and then um
currently trying to branch out and get
out of the fast food right now but
i mean if it's a job as a job pays my
bills and keeps my kid and what he needs
so
yeah
and yeah and you're a fighter as well oh
yeah yeah yeah i uh i actually met you
through uh
it's almost like a like a fight club
thing that they had organized here
what's it called
rough and rowdy so they have it they can
that's like this charleston convention
yeah man it's like a it's like a fight
club but it's uh yeah
you guys no helmets no helmets no head
gear no uh
no no head gear no knee pads shin pads
uh
no yards you get paired up and you guys
beat the crap yeah you get paired up and
you just beat crap at each other man
it's
uh
yeah it's a i think it's a west virginia
originated thing now i've seen it all
the time my buddies have done it cousins
have done it i've never done it and then
wyatt and talked me into it and i was
like
all right man i was like let's see let's
go so i ended up fighting an amateur
boxer and ended up winning so
good for you yeah it was pretty cool
you know
i've always been a fighter though man i
like to fight yeah only self-defense
i've actually never started a fist fight
before i've always ended them
that's great what uh
the most important thing you've learned
in your life most important thing i
learned in my life
time
life and love my friend
those all mixed together with me because
i've buried a lot
a lot of people
the only people that's left that carry
my last name is my son me and my
granddad that's it so like
time life and love that's all that
is one thing to me because i've lost a
lot of each
and
that's the best advice that i could give
or anything i could say as
as of that cherish it
because telling you it's
i took for granted
my time and my life and the love of the
people that i had around me and now that
they're all gone it's sitting here
wishing that i could have done things
differently
do things differently before you ever
have to think about man i wish i could
have done things differently do things
differently well you you've changed your
life yeah
drastically yeah i mean the role model
you are for your son is pretty great
yeah because i mean
you're if you're going to love somebody
love them
don't
you know
beat around the bush with them don't
fake it don't have two faces don't be a
snake in the grass just be real
you're if you love somebody love
somebody if you are going to put time in
somebody put time in somebody if that's
because that's your life take it
seriously see ain't problems tomorrow
you ain't promised the next five seconds
my dad went 6 30 he was gone at 6 40 10
minutes
you know take
don't take it for granted it's it's not
promised
all right zach thank you so much for
sharing your story oh you're not a
problem brother i appreciate it wish you
and your son lots of luck i appreciate
it
you